let's go fly your kite songs in my head
because it is excellent saving mr. banks
so saving mr. banks is the true ish
story about how Mary Poppins got adapted
to the big screen by Walt Disney Tom
Hanks plays Walt Disney we all know who
Walt Disney is he's a guy who died and
froze his head in a basement so I hear
probably not though he's mr. Disney and
he's been trying to get the author of
Mary Poppins to let him adapt to Mary
Poppins to the big screen for about 20
years now Emma Thompson plays P L
Travers the author of Mary Poppins Mary
Poppins is her baby it's like her Mickey
Mouse well Mickey Mouse to Walt Disney
as Mary Poppins to P L Travers P L
Travers is straight-up really proper
British lady the way she talks she's
like it's costly Walt Disney's this
really energetic charismatic guy you
know everyone calls him by his first
name do you not call him mr. Disney he
is Walt and at that point we have our
clash of the century between P L Travers
and Walt Disney and it's great because
there are two different personalities
they want two different things yet they
both want the same thing so it's a
really interesting concept this vision
of Mary Poppins is ultimately the one we
get and she hates it and although that's
one aspect of the movie it's not the
overall point of the movie because in
the course of this we get a peek behind
the curtain we get to see what Mary
Poppins is how she came to be what P L
Travers meant when she made her all of
this is really interesting it makes the
movie really enjoyable not just
enjoyable we're talking to heartstrings
enjoyable I'm telling you I swear to you
I almost cried like three times in this
movie we're talking like cry isn't good
this feel-good movie hit me with such a
feel-good moment a couple times I was
like I don't generally do that I mean
I'll cry when William Wallace is getting
his guts ripped out but not because of a
feel-good moment I'm telling you it
really hit you there is a segment in
this movie you will know it when you see
it's hitting you and your heart is
getting bigger if you have the Grinch
ohmmeter you had the little x-ray thing
and it showed your heart your heart
would grow three sizes and bust the
scale safe to say I had the strength of
ten grinches plus two but as much as
it's a feel-good movie it's also very
sad because behind any great thing there
is a bit of tragedy seeing that in this
movie really hits you in that part
really hit me hard
Farrell plays that aspect of her life
and he did a really good job in this
movie funny thing is this movie can show
everyone you can put it to rest when you
watch a movie and it doesn't follow the
book completely it's no big deal don't
be like I hated it cuz I didn't follow
the book because apparently Mary Poppins
does not follow the book at all it's a
movie classic this is one of those
movies I feel like when you're laying
there in Lamaze class with your pregnant
wife or whoever you should play this
movie me like okay to be a parent you
should watch this I'm scraping to find
anything I didn't like about saving mr.
banks the only thing I can say is that
it really ends abruptly I've said that
about few movies this year in this movie
certainly is one of the movies other
than that though everyone did a great
job in this movie it's well acted I love
the premise I loved seeing behind the
curtain as to what Mary Poppins is how
it came to be it's great it's a
feel-good movie it's sad it's relatable
it has a really strong message behind it
a movie doesn't make me well up in tears
and not walk away with my prestigious
title bestowed from me to it saving mr.
banks is awesome tacular one of the
bummers of this movies people are gonna
be like it wasn't like that Walt Disney
was actually a dick if you're missing
the point of the movie man let your
guard down just soak it in so saving mr.
banks have you seen it what did you
think about it and Mary Poppins have you
seen that what do you think of it made
me want to watch Mary Poppins whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]